tous les matins anaïs tram à ce courrier
pour un destinataire un peu particulier
le père noël comme chaque année la
mairie de plaisir collecte les centaines
de listes de cadeaux de ces jeunes
résidents nous avons mis en place la
boîte à lettres du père noël afin de
donner de la magie aux enfants afin
qu'ils puissent établir une lettre et
nous leur apportons après une réponse du
père noël pour écrire au célèbre barbu
toutes les adresses sont valables pourvu
qu'elle soit un peu imaginatives
côté cadeaux les petits plaisirs wa
savent exactement ce qu'ils veulent
et pour être sûr que le père noël ne se
trompe pas il colle même des extraits du
catalogue publicitaire les enfants
demandent toutes sortes de jouets ça va
du jouet clasico jouait un peu plus
évoluée technologique
il ya toutes sortes de demandes ya tous
les âges on a même des petits de 2 ans
et les parents qui écrivent une fois les
lettres lui celles ci sont transférés au
véritable secrétariat du père noël à
libourne près de bordeaux cependant
plaisir enverra un courrier à chaque
enfant après les fêtes lui recommandant
notamment d'être sage jusqu'à l'hiver
prochain
ah on a eu beaucoup de bons retours les
parents viennent nous remercier pour
avoir eu la réponse et les enfants sont
heureux ils ont eu la sensation que le
père noël les à leur avait répondu cette
boîte aux lettres située dans les
jardins de l'hôtel de ville reçoit entre
150 et 200 lettres par semaine preuve en
est que la magie de noël n'est pas prêt
de s'essouffler